boa tarde a todos e todos estamos aqui
nesse sábado aqui bacana
meu nome é fábio cabral eu vim conversar
um pouco com vocês sobre a flor
futurismo
vamos começar com um pequeno exercício
imaginem imaginem uma grande metrópole
habitada por pessoas como eu quero dizer
pessoas negras mas pessoas negras dos
mais diversos tipos das mais diversas
formas dos mais diversos tamanhos dos
mais diversos tons de pele pessoas
negras em toda a sua diversidade
imaginem também que essa grande
metrópole é uma cidade de altíssima
tecnologia
então imaginem carros voadores
arranha-céus celulares holográficos e
todo tipo de tecnologia maravilhosa que
vocês são capazes de imaginar falando em
maravilha tecnológica
imaginem que a tecnologia deste mundo é
movida a energia eletromagnética dos
espíritos ancestrais dos fantasmas
falando em espíritos ancestrais
imaginem que do alto de seus arranha
céus estão mães-de-santo empresárias com
poderes paranormais governando tudo
imaginem que todo esse progresso
científico maravilhoso andon lado a lado
com a preservação da natureza
então imaginem que por toda a cidade
há árvores arbustos plantas de todos os
tipos parques florestais em memsos
inclusive raízes enormes crescendo por
entre os pré
os imagine um mundo em que a cosmologia
e urupá simbolizadas na figura dos
orixás é a realidade deste mundo
vocês conseguem imaginar o mundo sem
gente opa
imaginei esse mundo se chama a q3 foi
inaugurado neste meu romance o caçador
cibernético da rua 13
gosto desses nomes enormes trechos a
chama atenção é eu criei esta cidade
quando me deparei com a palavra afro o
futurismo
em geral quando as pessoas vêem essa
palavra suspensão nossa futurismo que
diabos é isso que que é isso
o gesso o meu maluco pensei que novas
narrativas de novas histórias
interessantes
eu poderia criar a partir do que essa
palavra me vocal awa a futurismo tem
muitas definições se perguntam ah mas o
que é isso que é isso vamos discutir um
pouco dessas definições a partir também
da sua perspectiva que eu acabei
desenvolvendo muita gente classifica o
futurismo simplesmente como a mescla de
tradições africanas com tecnologia ou
definem como narrativas de fantasia e
ficção científica com o protagonismo
negro a gente mas será que seria só isso
porque se for só isso
uma chamada de ficção científica mesmo
não é mesmo enfim eu tenho problemas com
rótulos eu sei que é clichê falar isso
aí a não gasta de rato luz mas é difícil
nem ficar botar um roubo na sua cabeça a
emoção à flor está ali é legal mas como
passei entendeu o futurismo
eu comecei a entender ao futurismo como
uma mudança de perspectiva e quando
entendi isso entende isso como surgiu o
rótulo não na verdade mais tarde depois
de outro rótulo eu entendi que eu já era
afro futurista antes mesmo de saber que
essa palavra existia um louco
uma das perspectivas que eu usei
inconscientemente na criação deste
universo fantástico é a perspectiva da
afras entre cidade e o que é isso
em poucas palavras a felicidade entende
que o mundo é multicultural entende que
o mundo é diverso
não acho isso tão bem como diverso
diversas culturas diversas formas de se
pensar diversas formas de ciências
aproxime cidade entende o povo negro
como agente de saúde entende o povo
negro não como mero figurante de um
mundo euros entrado que nos é imposto um
do ano centrado que nos é imposto como
padrão como aniversário como universal
mas essa universalidade cada vez mais
está nítido que não existe a proceder
cidade entende que nós pessoas negras
somos agentes agindo de acordo como o
nosso com a nossa própria imagem
cultural de acordo com nossos próprios
interesses humanos
isso parece um monte de blá blá blá blá
blá mas é fundamental
e foi assim que eu conseguir criar essa
história
uma outra perspectiva que me interessa
bastante e que veio até mim até mesmo
antes da frança entre cidade
herói de rosto africano do professor
cláudio ford
nesse livro quando trabalhava como
livreiro acho esse livro la perdido lá
na seção de oncologia uns 10 anos atrás
mais ou menos eu fiquei maluco eu fiquei
louco
fiquei louco no lixo que era de origem
africana vou falar que rapidamente o
herói de um estado africano é aquele
aquele herói ou aquela heroína que vivia
a plenitude de sua civilização de sua
cultura
no seu mundo original lá no continente
mas em algum momento ele foi
enfraquecido e foi raptado abduzido por
alienígenas
ele foi levado para um outro mundo um
mundo estranho ele foi detido de toda a
sua cultura
de toda a sua civilização de todos os
seus saberes de toda sua filosofia de
todas o ciência de toda sua
espiritualidade e foi brutalizado foi
deixado no para ser escravizada du e
assim passou por muitos e muitos anos
até que ser herói ou heroína se libertou
com suas próprias mãos
não pelo decreto de alguma princesa
aliene china mas sim os seus próprios
esforços e mesmo no mesmo ainda despido
de seus saberes de sua cultura de sua
inteligência de sua filosofia de sua
ciência este herói ou heroína segue
reconstruindo o seu mundo perdido e
pisando firme neste mundo que nós
vivemos hoje
talvez para meio esquisito parece meio
estranho você ficar tentando explicar o
processo da forçada de as pôr a africana
por meio da mitologia mas é isso
o professor pai de ford propõe
ele entende que a mitologia tem esse
poder de curar o nosso trauma histórico
pois de acordo com as palavras dele
quando nós nos encontramos estamos à
mercê de um trauma seja individual ou
coletivamente os mitos e as lendas são
formas de estabelecer a nossa harmonia
que se encontra à beira do caos
todo mundo gosta de super-herói né agora
tá na moda nossa senhora tem um filme lá
do grupo a super heróis estava no mundo
meu deus acabou com metade da população
e salvou o porquê que os faróis agora se
tornam tão importantes né as pessoas
dizem que estão vendo os tempos
estranhos tempos difíceis embora para
alguns seja difícil desde sempre né você
parar pra pensar
acontece que o herói
a partir da perspectiva africana
simplesmente
uma coisa fantasiosa o mito não é
meramente uma inverdade como
infelizmente nós entendemos hoje
entendemos que o mito é sinônimo de
mentira e falsidade de uma mera fantasia
besta mas a partir do estilo africano
nós entendemos que os mitos na verdade
são absolutamente verdadeiros o que é
verdadeiro
lux a fantasia não são verdadeiros não
como fatos e sim como metáforas são
verdadeiros não fisicamente e sim meta
fisicamente porque a partir da
perspectiva africana segundo o professor
forte entendemos que o mito a mitologia
começa onde termina a investigação
científica e isso é fundamental
eu entendia com passei a entender que da
perspectiva africana esta ruptura entre
espiritualidade e ciência é uma
deturpação ocidental uma deturpação
européia que não faz sentido objetivo
africana os mitos não devem ser
compreendidos historicamente e sim
simbolicamente
dessa forma entendemos que o herói a
heroína representa simbolicamente nossas
lutas inevitáveis pelas nossas
inevitáveis transições que enfrentamos
na vida
a vitória do herói não a vitória
individual é uma vitória coletiva a
vitória contra as nossas forças
interiores que nos impedem de ir adiante
por isso que os heróis tanto incentivam
mesmo que você não se de consciência
disso incentivam por isso que você
quando um herói bem se você não se eu
posso vencer também mesmo que você não
admita isso porque parece um embaraçoso
é mesmo
vamos falar agora dos meus super heróis
de rosto africano favoritos os orixás
análise para falar de religião não não é
sempre bom deixar limite do que eu estou
falando a partir de uma perspectiva
mitológica filosófica e não de religião
não querer
impor nada a ninguém por exemplo os
orixás
os orixás da perspectiva e oruba
original não são simplesmente divindades
e sim ciências naturais representadas
simbolicamente ciências natal naturais
compreendidas de forma metafórica de
forma simbólica por exemplo o eixo ou o
corão bouchut o show não tem nada a ver
com aquele conhecido o ser maligno da
mitologia cristã
o echo também não é simplesmente um
peralta o malandro de charuto
ou uma entidade menor como vocês vêem
por aí de forma bastante esteriotipada
na perspectiva de roubar o show é o
próprio princípio dinâmico do universo
sem chuva não há movimento na galáxia
dessa perspectiva entendemos queijo é o
aspecto dinâmico que representa a
energia que move toda a realidade
vamos falar de um exemplo mais pessoal
o shopping eu cabral sou iniciado no
candomblé de tradição que tu iniciado
como filho de oxossi o que é o shopping
o shopping é orixá da caça orixá da
fartura como dizem por aí
mas será que é só isso o que a caça
se nós levamos em conta o que falamos
até aqui soube compreender a mitologia
de forma simbólica o que é o caçador
caçador é aquele que está lá na
segurança da sua comunidade
sai dessa segurança e vai lá pra uma
mata uma mata escura uma selva lugar
desconhecido lá enfrenta vários desafios
e volta com os frutos dessa aventura
volta com novos alimentos volta com
novas técnicas volta com
novos conhecimentos então podemos
entender a caça como metáfora da busca
por conhecimento podemos entender então
que eu achasse na verdade é a
representação simbólica do conhecimento
da arte
então quando há alguém declamando um
poema esculpindo um velho belo vaso
compondo uma música escrevendo um
romance podemos entender simbolicamente
metafóricamente que ali está presente o
oxóssi por isso que a maioria dos filhos
de oxóssi são escritores professores
tradutores artistas
por isso que eu filho de oxossi estou
aqui dividindo conhecimento com vocês
por isso que eu sou escritor porque
quando você se inicia
entendemos que simbolicamente você
desperta essas qualidades que sempre
existirão dentro de nós
falando em conhecimento não tem como
falar sobre as minhas perspectivas sobre
a profunda crise mesmo sem citar o
trabalho imprescindível o cheik anta
dill o maior cientista do século 20
já quinta diego compra comprovou usando
as leis do ocidente com seus phds ele
comprovou que tudo que nós conhecemos
hoje por ciência tecnologia a filosofia
arte literatura surgiu primeiro no vale
do nilo
criado por negros africanos e isso é
fundamental isso não quer dizer que um é
melhor que o outro é compreender de onde
você vem
isso é fundamental principalmente para
as pessoas negras para que entendam para
que nós possamos entender que nós não
defendemos simplesmente de escravos nós
descendemos dos pioneiros da humanidade
então só essa perspectiva já cai por
terra quando chamamos o futurismo de
mera mescla entre tecnologia e tradições
africanas não é futurismo dentro dessa
perspectiva é o resgate
deixe passado africano de tecnologia
ciência filosofia arte
falando em cientista aqui uma outra obra
minha cientista guerreira do facão
furioso obra que também se passa em que
tu 3 a sua metrópole maravilhosa eu
desenvolvi quando me deparei com a
palavra o futurismo essa personagem
cientista guerreira assim como caçador
cibernéticos são super heróis porque nós
precisamos de heróis sempre
simbolicamente metaforicamente ou até
mesmo fisicamente eu falo das minhas
obras porque é a partir delas que eu
desenvolvo o meua futurismo por mais que
eu faça um blablablá bonito
a partir dessas obras que eu explico
melhor apresenta melhor as minhas
perspectivas sobre esse assunto mas pra
fechar já está muito blábláblá
o que diabos é o agroturismo que entendo
que é o afr o futurismo o futurismo é
todo esse movimento de recriar o passado
transformar o presente e projetar um
novo futuro através da nossa própria
ótica muito obrigado a todos